Whassup baby? This week on Thug
Notes we gettin loose with The Scarlet Letter
by Nathaniel Hawthorne.
Up in Salem, Massachusets where
errybody got real tight assh*les, homies gather
to peep the public humuliation of some thick
hunny named Hester Prynne. See the One- time
found Hester guilty of sleepin round like
a skank and gettin knocked up. Now she gotta
sport a red “A” on her threads to signify
“Adultery.”
The people be all like, “Yo slut,
you best fess up the name of yo baby daddy.”
But Hester keeps it street and don’t snitch.
While she bein all hated on by the
hood, she peeps her ol' hubby in the crowd,
who til now she thought got ganked at sea.
This fool get all crunk and say
that the man she hoin it up with gotta get his too.
So he go by the fake
name of Doc Chillingworth and hit the streets
to find the fool who banged his woman.
After Hester get released from the
slammer, she shacks up in some dingy-ass digs
with her baby girl Pearl.
The local preacher man Dimmsdale
gets all sick and Doc Chill start nursing him
when he starts thinking, “Maybe this fool ill cuz
he got some fessin to do.”
So one night Chilly scope him out
while he sleepin and see a big red A on his chest.
Now Chilly know who been raw-doggin
Hester.
Then Hester gets tired of Chilly
bustin her baby daddy’s balls, and asks him to stop hatin.
But Chilly be all like, “Can’t
stop, won’t stop”! So Hester tell Dimmsdale
that Chillingworth her old hubby.
Later while Dimmsdale sermonizing, he
sees Hester and Pearl in the crowd,
loses his sh*t, and starts tellin errybody that
he’s Pearl’s daddy. Then he shrivels up
and dies like a bitch. Since Chilly ain’t
got nobody to f**k wit no more,
he up and dies too.
Years later, Hester goes back to
her cottage in da boonies where she builds
a rep for givin advice to other women. When
she dies, she gets buried next to Dimmsdale
with a big-ass “A” on their gravestone.
Even the scrappiest hoods know that
Hester’s A standin for Adultery, but listen
good, blood. That ain’t all it means.
Like when Hester start doin
righteous deeds for the community, homies
start thinkin the A stands for “able.”
And when peeps see a big “A” in the sky
after Winthrop buys the farm, they thinkin
it means “angel.”
But no matter how legit Hester
play, dat “A” isolating her from all the
other playas in town who frontin saying they
all pure n' uppity.
Ever since Adam took a bite out of
dat apple and got his ass booted out of Eden,
sin has isolated man from society, himself
and even God. And since dem Puritains ain’t
down with Hester’s bad self, she gotta live
in a cottage in bum-f**k nowhere.
Chilly’s sin of vengeance gets so
real, that he loses himself entirely. The
narrator even say dat that with his vengeance
all cashed out, he ain’t got nothin to do
but go chill with Satan.
But the truth up in here is that
all these self-righteous posers ain’t being
real and admitting that they just as human
as Hester. Cuz no matter how hard you try
to stick to the straight and narrow, acting
out is part of human nature. Anybody that
say they never trip in the face of temptation
is the real lying trick.
So what Hawthorne might be sayin
is: If errybody is a sinner, shouldn’t we
stop hating so much whenever someone f**ks
up?
Cuz if you gonna say life is based
on love and compassion, you gotta know how
to forgive, playa.
Stay in school, say no to drugs,
and tell all your friends about Thug Notes.
Catch yo ass next week! Peace.